hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us let's get into what
up though I'm rule dude this is an
answer to internet you can follow me on
instagram at one more dude my main
museum is awesome and if you really like
that go to one more dude dot-com is
jerking off to nudes of a girl who has
died weird or a nice tribute [ __ ]
nice tribute anybody has a [ __ ] like
sometimes I look at the old 70s porn
like John Holmes I [ __ ] dead
I'm not like jerking off to him cuz
whatever but I kind of am too cuz if you
think about it like one of the reasons
why asian porn isn't popping like that
cuz nobody wants to see someone like
some [ __ ] tiny dick like hmm you're
gonna see some ticket plows so yeah
jerking off to [ __ ] dead people is
cool and it really like it brings
everything together cuz you're like damn
is some black and white [ __ ] you're like
aw dammit Benteen [ __ ] like that's
[ __ ] crazy you know I mean like damn
son I thought like that was my [ __ ] but
like they've been licking ass for a
minute would you rather only jerk off to
the thought of your girlfriend or only
jerk off to your girlfriend getting
railed in a porn whoa it's kind of the
same synthesis uh yeah I could do both
can I so I got to watch my girl get
[ __ ] on porn oh I see I would rather
do the memory [ __ ] just cuz I [ __ ] a lot
of porn chicks but I wouldn't wife a
porn chick I'm not trying to change him
but like hey let's be real
I don't want to [ __ ] want our kids
like ya jacking off and there you are
[ __ ] it sucking 12 dicks that would
be a bummer
would your girl or would you rather your
girlfriend be able to read your thoughts
during sex all the time or all the time
except during sex I would kill myself on
either one [ __ ] that [ __ ] read my
thoughts during sex yeah
worst case scenario I'll just stop
[ __ ] her you know I mean like really
like hi you don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
thinking and then I just go in like what
the real clear head like God that ass
that [ __ ] would you kill a baby Hitler
if it had to be in a very gruesome way a
lot of people this is gonna be very this
is a nuanced response if it wasn't for
Hitler [ __ ] and uh it wouldn't be in
Israel and America wouldn't have a
middle class the way they do that there
was no competition whatsoever because
World War two totally decimated all of
Europe and America kicked off selling
[ __ ] to both sides so I don't I don't I
don't really [ __ ] with history I would
not kill baby Hitler I would allow
things to go as planned and just do my
best living in this world that's being
said I don't support anything he did I'm
just saying [ __ ] that as they're like
[ __ ] driving in there [ __ ] like
they're helped you get that [ __ ] car
their champion just saying there would
you rather be the president the Pope or
whoever is in charge of Korea well the
credit thing would be dope because you
could just [ __ ] all the Korean girls you
want that being said have you smelled
kimchi breath ruff
the Pope cuz they can [ __ ] young boys
and girls
you can go r.kelly or michael jackson it
doesn't [ __ ] matter and this loop
under the rug
never happened [ __ ] awoke folk now
and [ __ ] whatever dude you're [ __ ]
your [ __ ] kids dude just like all of
them [ __ ] out of here if you had the
flexibility to blow yourself would you
do it what if everybody no you did I
would say no homo first and no finishing
in my mouth cuz the one time like I'm
not at all my girls chest and I felt
really bad because I came fast and I
like went to kiss her on it and forgot I
did it and like I got a mouthful of my
own come huh yeah just felt like someone
smacked your lips and was like mad
tingly I was like oh this is the worst
I kept Altoids necks in my bed for the
next ten years after that [ __ ] I like
straight-up apologize after I noted oh
my god sorry would you rather go into a
coma and not wake up until you're 75 or
die tomorrow died tomorrow like the way
I look at it is like I [ __ ] hate
young people now so I can't even imagine
like waking up 75 years later and
they're like you're not allowed to say
people it's it's a it's not inclusive
enough I'm like what the [ __ ] you're not
doing really [ __ ] that I just land like
bam [ __ ] like let's just [ __ ] get
it
[ __ ] yeah man if I'm in a coma for like
I don't know man just [ __ ] kill me
dude would you have to [ __ ] the hottest
girl celebrity who has a dick or Vin
Diesel with a [ __ ] I don't even know
man
I look I was just on the show yesterday
I was like years ago I was walking
behind jennifer Love Hewitt and she had
a fat ass I was just I would have to
[ __ ] her I'd go doggy style in the
[ __ ] before I was like I'm like can
you imagine like looking Vin Diesel dead
in his eyes as your [ __ ] and Terenas
[ __ ] hi [ __ ] me dude we're gonna
bisexual for the day before I do that
[ __ ] that's rough would you rather have
teeth where your hair is or hair where
your teeth are
that's [ __ ] you for whoever came up with
that one it's [ __ ] weird man
it's wrong with you [ __ ] weirdo yeah
man look here's the I'll go with a head
full of teeth because I'm I'm going bald
no teeth [ __ ] yeah yeah you know as
money I make off the tooth fairy
if you could bang any celebrity but you
have to make a sex tape with them that
would go viral would you do it no I
haven't seen anybody ever like besides
Ray J like I don't there's been nobody
that's been like hey man you're that
dude from the [ __ ] sex tape yeah
you're the [ __ ] like chicks give up the
[ __ ] they blow up dudes they just like
go to [ __ ] away
and I don't like taping sex I like to
really just be in the moment
ladies be here now just really enjoy you
soak you in forget about that jennifer
Love Hewitt question all right would you
rather have only the internet only TV
only movies and only music I guess music
for me only music because that way i got
like i got theme music while i'm doing
cool [ __ ] that's like yeah that's it
like there's so many songs that'll bring
me back to a place like BAM
oh I remember I was doing this when that
happened would you accept a million
dollars to be deported from the US you
can never come back but you get to take
one person with you million bucks
depends on where I go cuz a million
dollars some places ain't [ __ ] right
yeah yeah I would probably I don't like
it here that much I'm starting to [ __ ]
hate Americans all of y'all like really
and I'm sure you hate me too so it's
like yeah I think it'd be best if I just
leave would you date your dream girl if
for two-day for it for two days every
week she had to dress like a Juggalo
[ __ ] yeah dude that'd be like a bonus do
you know how long I've been trying to
[ __ ] a juggle leg I'm knocked down a
skinhead [ __ ] I actually she sucked my
dick but like I'm trying to get all of
the hard things down you know I mean I
want like a [ __ ] juggle at a little
dwarf you [ __ ] tall basketball player
little girl like I won't like anything
Bengali I'll take anything yeah totally
dude [ __ ] yeah man hit add me